hey guys now i'm going to show you how
to get the mac os 10 theme for your
rocket dock now this is not the mac os
10 theme this is a different theme that
came built into rocket dock so i'm going
to show you how to get the mac os 10
theme first of all open a web brow
and the link in your description is this
one right here
you're going to copy and paste it into
your address box or just click on it
or open a new tab so you can continue
watching this video
and it'll take you directly to the mac
os 10 skin that i recommend if you don't
like it just hit skims again
and search um maybe mac
and it'll come up with a whole bunch of
mac uh skins
so
uh what i did was i copied and pasted
that url and of course you come to this
page scroll all the way down to here
where we can download file
hit the open button of course i've
already downloaded it i'm going to
once you open it and extract it you're
going to extract it to the following
place
my computer
local disk
program files
and rocket dock
which should be right
here and then skins and you're going to
right click and paste it into skins now
mine is named mac osx
so it will be
down here
right there so i've pasted it into
program files rocketdoc skins
so now when we exit out
we can go to our docs settings
and hit style
click here and we'll be able to find the
mac os 10
leopard theme
we hit okay
and bam has already been now it's going
to look a little upside down because
it's at the top
so if you want to put it at the bottom
we will just go to doc settings again
and we would say position
and bottom which would put it at the
bottom and it will look exactly like
your rocket dock
i'll give a little edge offset so it's
above the start menu or taskbar so
that's how you get your rocket dock to
have the mac os 10 theme
and i know a lot of people like to
unlock their taskbar and throw it at the
top of the page
so that is how you do that and then lock
the taskbar again simply drag it
sorry lock the taskbar
and so your taskbar is up here and your
rocket dock is down at the bottom
that is how you get the mac os 10 theme
in windows vista hope you enjoyed this
tutorial and subscribe for more peace